and you know colombia it has the very
the weather very similar we're by the
equator so it's very similar we don't
have a
seasons we have i mean we don't have
like very differentiation it doesn't
vary that much because but we do have
winter and we don't have like summers
yeah it sounds very i would love to go
i'm afraid i would be kidnapped no then
they don't
they don't even know who you are
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because you can never remember where all
the countries are so it's always fun to
discover a new one like i didn't know
nicaragua was right next to costa rica
have you guys ever heard of nicaragua
yeah because we schooled in england so
you've talked about the uh
not enough uh like uh people of color
minorities represented on television
is having you on my show does that count
at all yeah
it's really diverse right now it's like
50 percent the very center of the people
on tv
yeah yes yeah this is like an all-time
high for cbs yeah
all right and if we can stop for a
second i want to say to you you have a
very cute soft like a girly voice thank
you a lot of people say the reason
people have girly voices something bad
happened to him at that age where you
touched at an early age or were you fine
that's the creepiest question i've ever
heard and no but it's so inappropriate
it's not even funny but do you do a
little exercise yeah i ride a bike about
recumbent bike i should date do you
watch whatever
let me finish i dave
i know it's your show but i have a
little curtis sorry a little respect
i'm much older than you i understand by
the way that snow is getting a little
brighter up there all right thank you
are you all single
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
they're all single wait why are you
always curious about this though
it's my job
i want them to be happy you smell
terrific you really smell great what you
can do do you mind if i ask you
i mean i mean i knew you'd smell nice
but
you know you know you uh uh i know you
didn't want to come on here for the
longest time so why finally after uh
nearly four and a half years did you
decide to come on
i don't know i i thought it was one
reason but i'm sure that couldn't what
is the reason you thought it was i
wanted to pay my hotel bill
okay so that you thought that was one
reason but of course that's not really
the reason why what was the re i mean
you must have had a change of heart
about something
no actually
i don't know because i thought that i
would never want to do this show with
you now why
now let's let's just explore this a
little why
because you thought i was uh
[Applause]
[Music]
what's the best prank you ever pulled
well i when my aunt chippy was at work i
painted her house orange and green once
and she was not happy really the whole
outside of the house was
yeah but the best i think the best prank
i ever pulled was i told the guy i told
the guy that five years from now i'm
gonna give you my show and then when the
five years came i gave it to him and
then i took it back almost instantly
but it turns out tom didn't give it to
you bad
oh i didn't read it well
i don't like talking about husbands
right wendy
well i don't mind talking about husbands
i don't mind he's fabulous
okay
um
roseanne
i have to know what is it like to be the
last black president
seriously
what's it like for this to be the last
time you ever talked to a president
she's from kentucky she went to new york
and she was hanging out at all the
parties doing what paris and lindsay do
you know dancing whatever and so he held
a press conference to announce whether
or not she was going to retain her crown
and then she started to cry so i just
wanted to thank donald is giving me a
second chance and really there he is
[Applause]
rosie o'donnell is disgusting i mean
both inside and out you take a look at
her she's a slob she talks like like a
truck driver you've called women you
don't like fat pigs
dogs
slobs
and disgusting animals
your twitter account only rosie
o'donnell
you you know you have some shock value
to you i mean you're on the cover of
your book you're wearing a fur and you
knew that there would probably be animal
rights action you know this whole
interview is becoming a defensive
interview
are you wearing leather shoes
you know what i mean all right come on
can you read this is really cool
can i read yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i wear fur that was killed 15 years ago
i work for animal rights stop it with
and you do this and you're mean and
you're that you are not the one to
interview a person who does human sorry
are we serious
what's the most number of lap dances
you've had in one night
jay my mother's watching the show so
actually no wait a minute the show's
canceled right nobody's watching the
show
if you could use makeup or your phone
one last time which one would you pick
your makeup or your phone is this what
you think girls have trouble choosing
yeah absolutely
yes is this men assuming that that's
what girls would have to choose between
now this is not a question can you
really go anywhere without your cell
phone yes how long can you go without
looking at me many hours
hours many hours i don't believe it
absolutely i have to you know when i'm
at a dinner table i like to be
present and talking good quality eye
contact ladies learn
listen
ladies boys
excuse me come on you see us on our
phones
we got respect we're on the date right
now we got our have you seen the news
boys and girls we can all learn where
are we in what's that we're in big sur
oh right but are you in a cabin
somewhere yes it's a sort of lodge and
big
sorry and then and so you go out to walk
the dog
well
no
i sort of
don't they allow dogs at the hotel
aren't you supposed to let people talk
on the show
number nine is is there anything you
haven't hosted that you want to host
oh this is a trick right
you get me to host the tonight show and
then take it back from no no no no
i'm not gonna listen listen lucy i'm not
charlie brown i don't fall for that
trick
hey this is southside steve and this is
southside steve tv and this is bill burr
that's your question
i'm just saying who you are oh yeah all
right i don't like you creeped me out
with that big microphone in that country
western shirt oh no this isn't country
western it's like it's hip now to wear
this this is my nightclub look yeah come
on
all right
this is this is i guess this is the
internet right you just sort of just
throw it out there i just throw it out
there i figure you're a funny guy out
there i'll throw it out there too well
here's the deal bill's a comedian he's
at the punch line he's in town and
you're a funny guy you've got these
routines in your head so i figure i'll
toss you a mic and you go and i'm gonna
do stand up in front of nine people in a
radio station no i'm not doing that well
you're taking the fun out of south side
steve tv i'll take uh how about i give
you five bucks i want to watch you line
dance and you're i'm a racist
you're no you're the weirdest looking
person on the planet earth thank you
thank you that doesn't no that doesn't
help me at all that's that's very kind i
don't mean that as a negative it does
nobody i can't describe the fact that i
have a full head of hair that's what's
going on well yeah sure
i don't
if you weren't famous and you robbed a
bank yeah and the dude was describing
you to like a police sketch artist yeah
he'd be like no seriously what did he
look like
nobody
nobody looks like this
nobody looks like you i can't i can't
believe i'm looking at you all the time
but do you like my mic
no i don't i don't please is that
comfortable is this uncomfortable this
is yeah no don't man honestly can i can
i take the mic sure now that's number
the number one thing you don't do
as i learned that in broadcasting school
you never give up the microphone see now
i have the power
this bob barker thing yeah your uh what
is this rock 101.5
this is the worst interview i've ever
done and he's wearing stetson cologne or
something it's just really
over overpowering
you know what he looks like he looks
like the first guy who gets his ass
kicked in a steven seagal
movie the background guy behind the uh
the big kingpin wouldn't you handle this